- my privilege to teach you this  semester  enjoy your winter breaks and Merry  Christmas sup ladies excited for tonight  it is the last day of our last fall  semester of college ever  [Music]  can you take a photo of all of us of  course  where's how nothing but she was tiny  vodka sodas earlier but she looked  really good she's we should no let her  go back by herself she's fine if I were  missing I'd want you to unleash the  bloodhounds and track me down she was a  dko last night still creating problems  all right hello hello I'm worried  something bad happened it's Peter break  could just be a delay of some sort snow  my friend is missing nine times out of  ten the girls just with a boyfriend I  will bring you to your knees  [Music]  [Music]  what this can't be real this rule has  200 years of history many sacrifices  have been made to keep our traditions  alive you're all insane  tired of hiding  and Titan is running  to mess with the wrong sisters  you  you